My name is Mattias and I'm eight years old.
My brother is Christian and he's ten, and he has autism.
What I like about Christian is his sense of humor.
He makes me laugh a lot.
The most fun I have with Christian is when we go into the ocean and play.
When Christian and I are in the ocean, you can't really tell Christian has autism.
Chris would like to swim across the ocean.
It's hard for him to talk and when he does,...
...it's like, it just comes out not right.
He has the words locked inside of him.
Sometimes people stare and it's a little uncomfortable.
At night, there's always a loud sound of Christian crying in the other room.
It's one of the times that its hard to have a brother with autism.
I would like the world to actually find something that could help Christian with his autism.
April is Autism Awareness Month.
Visit autismspeaks.org.